[Musique]
c'est très heureux aujourd'hui de vous
parler d'une barque avec lequel j'ai un
lien marshall si vous connaissez
marshall ses marques historiques à
marque anglaise fabrique des amplis
guitare au son juste extraordinaire je
suis un très gros amoureux de sept
matchs 17 ans clip je crois que ça fait
mouche avant tout c'est que j'ai une
grosse vingtaine d'années que j'ai cet
homme qui a fait 25 ans le basket 100 m
et quand on m'a proposé tient à ce que
voudrait ce que ça t'intéresse de faire
une vidéo en partenariat avec marshall
pour présenter leur nouvelle enceinte
connectés et j'ai sauté sur l'occasion
c'est très heureux de pouvoir vous
présenter aujourd'hui deux enceintes
connectés marshall a town de staël man 2
qui sont vraiment intéressante pour
plusieurs points on n'est pas dans la
même configuration que mambé 700 erronée
cyrus en a qui est beaucoup plus petit
ça c'est lactones de celle là c'est la
stalle man 2 marshall a vraiment fait un
très beau boutry packaging j'aime
beaucoup tout cas on reste dans le côté
très classe le côté anglais c'est
vraiment ce qui fait la force de cette
marque vous avez déjà un logo de les
gens et je dis pas ça pour envoyer faire
j'aime beaucoup je vraiment vous dis une
affinité avec cette marque vous avez une
boîte qui est franchement bien cette
très simple très sobre
tous les codes marshall ça c'est
vraiment cool et sans tout ce qui est
très intéressant et google vous avez
donc google assistant sur ces ensembles
à sur la petit lac town de et sur la
plus grosse à l'instinct de mort de bon
ça c'est bien alors après il ya quand
même des différences entre ces deux
produits
il n'y a pas que la taille il n'y a pas
que la puissance il ya un doute en
termes de connectique déjà j'ai commencé
par montrer comment configurer
configurer la qualité sont configurés
avec vous la semaine bordeaux vous allez
voir c'est très facile
la première chose à faire c'est branché
l'enceinte première chose qu'elle va
faire elle va commencer par
s'initialiser on allait les deux bouts
et résistants qui clignotent
elle commence à démarrer voilà donc là
il vous parle a dit d'installer
l'application google comme chose que
j'ai déjà fait
vous voyez que vous avez sur le dessus
déjà bien les petites lumières qui sont
arrivés si vous êtes vous dire quoi ça
sert dans quelques instants
première chose à faire c'est d'aller
dans mon application google phone plage
et faire a ajouté j'ai déjà une maison v
configurer un appareil a ajouté un
nouvel appareil dans la maison donc ça
c'est bon c'est dans la maison va
rechercher l'appareil et là il la trouve
directement marshall stones doors paf je
clique suivant puissent correctement
d'appareils connectés c'est hyper rapide
avez vous entendu le son oui j'accepte
les contributions ou est ce qu'ils se
trouvent
on est dans le studio j'ai aussi mon
wifi suivant mémoriser le mot de passe
pour le wifi pour les prochains
appareils
oui elle est le connecte directement sur
mon wifi pensent-ils au fond sur la
configuration du bouillon assistant de
plus voilà j'accepte tout ça une valise
j'avance activé veille ce match sur
votre appareil
j'accepte l'assistance c'est déjà
reconnaître votre voix des résultats
trop génial bonne voie donc ça c'est bon
j'accepte you yet à poum demande adresse
bien évidemment je vous la montre pas
mais c'est déjà validé j'ai mon compte
spotify premium qu'existe la john terry
captée par à mon écran aussi qu'ils
acceptent et là il en train de
configurer mon enceinte marshall
stanmore deux bonds à la configuration
est assez rapide sur une configuration
un peu classique du google assistant
donc c'est bon je les ajouter
directement google home on voyait ça se
connectent y perd facilement premier
point positif c'est que ça va se
connecter directement à votre wifi votre
iphone en wifi de votre maison de ce que
vous voulez de votre appartement
wi fi du studio ici ce qui est vraiment
cool c'est que maintenant avec la
commande vocale
je peux lui demander de jouer de la
musique baroque et google je vous la
playlist les légendes du rock sur
spotify d'accord voici une playlist
spotify intitulé légende ouvre et voilà
ça marche au sol le temps qui est
vachement bien si vous pouvez devenir
complètement les piloter à la voix c'est
tout l'intérêt pour marshall d'équiper
leur enceinte de google assistant alors
à savoir et aussi des modèles qui
existent avec un jean
avec ça en france mais en anglais si ce
temps est plus utilisé qu amazon avec ça
donc je pense que c'est plutôt des
enceintes comme ça qu'ils pourront vous
correspond si par contre vous êtes plus
amazon alexa vous aussi les commander
sur le site de marshall
vous les trouvez dans aucun problème
alors ce qui est vraiment cool c'est que
vous avez effectivement d'avoir deux
modèles un modèle qui est un peu plus
petits à vous d'aller un peu plus grand
dans les deux cas vous avez des enfants
stars et dans les deux cas vous avez
deux tweeters de 15 points fervent se
faire au niveau du seul coup d'un seul
ici de crampes loi tandis que la c1 50
watts en termes de puissance bien
évidemment vous avez une différence sur
un acteur de la plus petite des deux
vous allez avoir 103 décibels à un mètre
ce qui est déjà relativement et nantes
tandis que sur l'instinct de mort 2 vous
avez cent sept décibels à m croyez moi
c'est très très fort le mieux pour vous
en rendre compte c'est quand même de
vous mettre un peu de musique dessus
comme ça vous dirait ce que vous en
pensez
voilà ça déjà ça ronronne j'adore le son
c'est vachement bien
l'ag que le micro la rencontre ça
c'est bien évidemment montesson
c'est hyper forte
vous avez bien évidemment complètement
la possibilité de venir choisir alors
moi je me suis connecté directement
rendez-vous tous depuis mon téléphone
mais vous pouvez l'écouter en wi fi
voyages typiquement ici là hop on est
connecté en wifi sur l'ac thann board
sur l'acte en deux la gelée connecté en
bluetooth vous aussi connecté en
auxiliaires ici parce que vous avez une
prise jack prix jack propre sac d'un
côté et de l'autre
donc ça c'est vachement bien bouton de
volume sans fin ce qui fait que vous
pouvez tourner à l'infini dans un sens
ou dans l'autre ça marche parfaitement
bien vous avez votre petite jauge ici
vous permet de vous rendre compte du
volume pour venir régler vos basses plus
ou moins de base comme vous le souhaitez
et ici vos aiguë votre idole autre point
qui est là vous avez un bouton pour
venir l'allumer et pour éteindre la
musique directement donc pas besoin
d'aller directement sur mon application
ou de faire une commande vocale
je peux le faire directement la fin
c'est vachement bien et là je peux venir
voilà le micro et merveilles il faut
venir désactiver micro pour les
questions de vie privée si je veux pas
que google puisse m'écoute en permanence
aussi le réactiver le micro est activée
ce panneau de commande vous l'avez sur
l'acte en deux vous l'avez exactement de
la même manière sur l'ac thann bord de
la grosse différence vouloir trouver ici
c'est vous avez rca vous retrouver ici
deux entrées rca pour venir brancher des
appareils en externe en rca ça c'est
vachement bien vous pouvez le faire sans
la stan mort 2 mais pas sur l'acte en
deux personnellement ce que j'adore
vraiment une saison 5 c'est que vous
avez un souk et ipc du som marshall je
sais pas si vous êtes guitariste si vous
vous intéressez à ces typologies de son
vous avez un son qui est quand même
relativement tipi alors ressenti très
joli mais si vous écoutez comme moi du
rock des sons guitare du métal
franchement le fonds est génial si vous
écoutez une musique autres ça peut être
dur et demi ça pète du blues ça peut
être de l'électro ça peut être d'une
musique classique vous avez une couleur
musicale qui est forcément un petit et
parce que ces leçons marshall sel sont
emblématiques marshall mais en moins ça
ira parfaitement bien pour tout type de
musique
je suis très très très grand fan j'adore
vraiment le la qualité le travail qui
est fait par marchal là dessus en plus
de ça vous allez ça avec de
l'intelligence artificielle avec un
google assistant alors si comme moi vous
avez livre maison à google assistant
vous avez des ampoules philip sion vous
avez une télé connectée
vous avez tous connectés c'est un vrai
plaisir et le truc vachement bien aussi
c'est que vous pouvez l'utiliser pour
faire du roaming souhaité faire du multi
room vous en mettez une dans une pièce
nue dans une test dans une autre
yes c'est vraiment bien se permettra
d'écouter de la musique un peu partout
comme vous le souhaitez ça c'est aussi
pour moi un point essentiel
je vous considère est bien évidemment si
vous aimez ce soir et cette typologie de
son équiper votre maison font darshan
mais évidemment après c'est calme un
certain coup je vous donnais le tag est
anase instant mais si vous avez par
exemple google
hominick vous mettez les gens comme moi
j'en unama dans la salle de bains une
lune dans ma cuisine
mettez ça dans le salon vous l'avez un
ensemble principale déjà c'est vachement
beau c'est très déco vous permet d'avoir
du son de faire du multi room avec vos
autres enceintes aux pois qui est
vachement bien je suis pas obligé de
parler trop fort pour que je puisse
commander google assistant par exemple
imaginons je met la musique un volume
suffisamment fort et j'ai pas envie
d'hurler pour google montendre il ya un
travail qui a été fait du point de vue
un générique est vraiment bien réussi
clé vous parler normalement ils arrivent
à détacher votre voix du reste de la
musique
quelle heure est il il est 14 heures 5
tout ça c'est bien beau mais quand l'été
en terme de budget vous vous en douterez
vous avez une différence entre lactones
2 et la stalle mort de la différence va
vraiment dépendre de votre intérieur si
à mon avis vous avez une pièce de
l'ordre de 30 mètres carrés et que vous
n'avez pas forcément besoin du rca aller
sur la tonne 2 elle ira parfaitement
bien le conviendra à l'est déjà
suffisamment puissante
je pense que ça suffira largement et
coûte 299 euros c'est l'acte en deux
avec google assistant si maintenant vous
avez une pièce qu un peu plus grande
cinquante mètres carrés 60 m² et que
vous avez besoin éventuellement dû
verser en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que le rca c'est plus optionnel vu qu'on
est sur une enceinte connectés mais si
toutefois vous pensez de pouvoir besoin
de vercia ou alors que vous avez une
plus grande pièce aller sur l'ac thann
mort 2 elle développe davantage de
puissance le soin toujours hyper bien et
elle coûte 399 euros saison soit à se
destine à qui elle se destine aux
amoureux des jags la marque toute
première chose c'est vraiment les
amoureux de marshall et au delà des
amoureux de marshall toutes les
personnes qui veulent une belle qualité
audio équivalents sont un peu cheap et
un peu racé qui avait coûté du
rock'n'roll mais pas qu'eux qui aiment
la musique éclectique qui vont se
balader entre plusieurs univers mais
quand ils veulent en son guitar ils
veulent à son guitar qu'envoyer qui
veulent vraiment quelque chose de
particulier
marshall c'est une marque qui traverse
les époques continue à exister
aujourd'hui menton guitariste suis très
heureux de pouvoir vous les présentez se
trouve vraiment hyper intéressante à
regarder si j'ai encore mon ampli
marshall chez moi que j'utilise il ya
franchement une raison a vous de me dire
maintenant ce que vous en pensez est ce
que vous avez
du matériel marshall est ce que vous
êtes guitariste est ce que vous avez un
ampli guitare marshall est ce que vous
avez un casque aussi marshall faille à
pas mal de deux produits qui ont été
déclinées dites moi ce que vous en
pensez quoi si vous avez des produits de
la marque en bas aux commentaires et au
final est ce que vous pourriez vous
laisser tenter et si oui ashton deux
stades mort 2 c'est à vous de me dire
tout ça vous a été remarquée tout ça en
bas en commentaires questions
suggestions interrogations tout ce que
vous voulez et à rester connectés parce
qu'on va continuer à parler d'audio en
continu par les deux produits hyper cool
de plein de choses il ya plein de
surprises donc vous donne rendez vous
dès demain je vous embrasse
ciao
[Musique]